okay well first of all I want to know
how proud are you of this beautiful
woman right here very very very very
proud I think everybody works hard I
don't think anybody knows what it's like
inside of the studio there's four walls
it gets brutal sometimes and you just
got to keep working and she kept working
she was positive through the whole
experience she came in with zero train
Dance Experience like like she she's not
a dancer and she left the dancer so I'm
proud we gave it our best goal come on
[Music]
how are you feeling uh mentally and
physically uh physically I will be
seeing a physical therapist tomorrow you
know to work work all this out yes
literally some massages I got everybody
on Deck okay everybody's on call
um mentally I don't know I don't think I
expected this but I'm actually good I'm
okay I made it a lot further than I
actually thought that I was going to I
surprised myself every single week for
what I could actually do what this body
can do
um as well as just being able to make
great friends having a once in a
lifetime experience unless they do
All-Stars I hope they call me back if
they do that yeah come on I would do it
again actually
maybe
um nothing just fell up at the sky okay
um but yeah I there's just been a lot of
things that I've taken away from this
and I'm really really happy that I did
it I just feel like a new
person kind of like I feel like I'm
stepping into a new stage in my life and
this was definitely something that
propelled me into that yeah I'm
wondering how this experience is going
to affect the music if we're gonna see
you dancing like doing stuff in the
video listen I have I have a
choreographer right here yes I got a
choreographer taking over everything but
also
um I have an announcement tomorrow about
new music I didn't plan it this way
totally but
um I do have a new announcement on music
it's fun people need to feel again
people need to dance again people need
to sing again people need to boy you
gonna get me in trouble y'all better
start singing
he's gonna get me in trouble the music's
not even out yet come on
um but no I'm just I'm really grateful
to be able to still do this and that
people still
that people still love me thank you so
much for just still caring about my
music and what I'm doing like see now
I'm emotional I wasn't emotional but now
I'm emotional because to see all the
people and like it's really really sweet
because you know with how it is now you
can do something in the next day your
nobody cares you know so I'm I'm I am
just so I am so grateful and I'm so
happy to still be doing this and I hope
you love the new music when you hear it